La guerre contre les voleurs de zébu.
Elle est menée par des militaires
dont nous suivons un détachement.
Au total, ils sont 1000
à travers toute l'île.
Et déjà sur la route,
un peloton de gendarmes exhibe
fièrement une première prise.
6 gamins, il s'agirait de Dahales.
Ils ont 14, 15, 16 ans,
tous marqués par l'arrestation.
L'un d'entre eux porte
le même foulard rouge
et les amulettes que Ravak,
le chef voleur
que nous avions rencontré.
- Je ne sais pas pourquoi
ils m'ont arrêté.
Je crois que c'est juste
parce que j'avais ces grigris.
Ils ne m'ont pas attrapé
dans la forêt mais au village.
Mais je ne suis pas Dahale.
- Arrête de mentir !
En ces temps d'opération
anti-voleurs de zébus,
le grigri vaut d'abord
comme une preuve à charge.
Mais qu'il soit simple
berger ou vrai dahale,
tous ici croient à la magie
et aux vertus de ces amulettes.
- Ils mettent toutes sortes
de choses à l'intérieur des grigris
et ça leur permet de se protéger
des balles et de les éviter.
Celui-là,
ils l'utilisent
pour se rendre invisible.
Ces deux-là se ressemblent,
elles servent à éviter la fatigue.
Selon moi, c'est clair.
Ce gars-là est un dahale.
Un voleur de zébus.
C'est pour ça qu'ils mettent
le foulard et l'amulette.
Ultime preuve brandie par
les gendarmes, un fusil fait maison,
retrouvé chez un suspect.
- C'est l'arme utilisée par
les dahales, les bandits !
Ils arrivent dans le village,
ils font les pillages,
ils enlèvent tous les bétails.
Et actuellement ils ont essayé
de voler aussi des marmites,
et des matelas et tout ce
qui se trouve dans la maison.
Et après, ils les amènent dans la forêt.
Bien escorté, le camion de gendarmes part
déposer les 6 adolescents au pénitencier.
Ces suspects risquent
5 à 10 ans de prison.
Dirigés par le capitaine Rodin,
les militaires ont pour mission de sécuriser
un village d'une zone très reculée.
Ils pénètrent dans la forêt primaire
où ils risquent une embuscade,
des gamins voleurs de zébus.
- La consigne, c'est une distance
de cinq mètres entre chaque homme.
Préparez vos armes.
Vous rechargez maintenant.
C'est bon ?
C'est dans cette même jungle que
les dahales cachent leurs zébus volés
et préparent leurs attaques.
Sortis du labyrinthe tropical
après plus de 50 km,
les soldats arrivent épuisés au village.
Pour faire leur caserne provisoire,
ils ont réquisitionné l'école du village.
Ici, la présence des militaires rassure.
Depuis qu'ils sont là,
les dahales n'attaquent plus.
Mais à peine arrivés,
un problème majeur resurgit.
L'opération anti-voleurs de zébu
a commencé il y a 3 mois
et les militaires n'ont jamais été payés.
Au tableau noir, ils reprennent
leurs réflexes d'écolier.
Additions, multiplications,
les chiffres sont astronomiques.
- C'est l'argent qu'on nous doit.
Nous, on cherche juste à être payés,
à être tranquilles.
Mais si on n'est pas
payé aujourd'hui, on part.
On s'en fout, on rentre à la maison.
- Il y en a marre ! Maintenant,
il faut qu'on aille voir les chefs.
Ce n'est plus possible,
on n'a rien à manger !
Le capitaine Rodin sera trouvé les quelques
rares billets pour éviter la mutinerie.
Devant notre caméra, les militaires
repartent du bon pied,
pour suivre la piste
d'un troupeau de zébus volés.
Les Dahales, les voleurs agissent
dans l'immensité des plateaux et forêts.
Ils ont toujours un temps d'avance
sur les soldats.
Sans hélico, sans voitures, sans moto,
les militaires enquêtent à pied
dans les petits hameaux du coin.
- Bonjour, comment ça va ici ?
Et la sécurité dans le village, ça va ?
- Oui, ça va.
Cette toute petite communauté
est encore traumatisée.
Récemment, ils ont assisté au plus
gros vol de zébus de la région.
- Vous savez, ce vol de 400 zébus,
juste à côté de notre village.
Les militaires n'ont jamais retrouvé
les bêtes. Pas un seul zébu.
Dans ce coin de brousse, encore une fois,
l'armée arrive trop tard.